[Musik]
wer zahlt die rechnung die
bundesregierung stellt klar die hilfen
für unternehmen werden ab januar nicht
in der bisherigen form weiter gezahlt
dicker smog erhöht die korona gefahr in
indien trifft das virus auf viele
patienten mit vorgeschädigten lungen zur
europameisterschaft mit löw der dfb
spricht der bundestrainer das vertrauen
aus trotz spanien desaster
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den heute nachrichten hin zu beginn
einer neuen woche für den sport ist
norbert lehmann an meiner seite
doch von mir und wir beginnen mit den
enormen hilfsgeldern mit denen der bund
derzeit firmen unterstützt die vom teil
shutdown betroffen sind auf dauer da
sind sich kanzleramt und
wirtschaftsminister einig sei das nicht
zu finanzieren
unions-fraktionschef brinkhaus fordert
ja die länder auf sich stärker an den
crooner milliarden zu beteiligen und
erntet weiter scharfen widerspruch
die aktuellen summen sind in der tat
hoch für november und dezember zahl der
bund der betroffenen firmen bis zu 75
prozent ihres umsatzes aus dem
vorjahresmonat
das wird insgesamt etwa 30 milliarden
euro kosten
angekommen ist bei den unternehmen
bislang allerdings wenig katrin lindner
berichtet die eisstöcke fürs
eisstockschießen haben sie umsonst
rausgeholt auch weihnachtsdeko geht ins
lager zurück ihr unternehmen hat die
potsdamerin auf zwei beine gestellt
veranstaltungs service und gastronomie
november hilfen braucht sie dringend
heute muss ich für zehn angestellte
gehälter zahlen der november ist bisher
ihr härtester monat
wir warten sehr dringend darauf wie
wunder eigentlich zugesagt dass sie im
nur wenn man noch fließen jetzt ist
plötzlich nur von abschlagszahlungen die
rede
fakt ist dass wir das kurzarbeitergeld
vorfinanzieren müssen dass auch die
überbrückungs gelder für september und
oktober noch nicht gezeigt wurden und
dass wir natürlich einen
liquiditätsengpass haben seit
vergangenem mittwoch erst können
november hilfen beantragt werden 55.000
anträge sind bisher eingegangen ein
aufwändiger prozess so das feedback der
branche beim brandenburger verband
sammelt sich frustration weil ein
langfristiger vorbereiten können weil
man wusste ja dass der herbst und der
winter kommt und es kann sich doch mir
keiner erzählen dass man dann schön
dachte ohne entsprechende impfstoffe
dass man jetzt einfach so über den berg
kommt und dann ohne zahlung hier
weitermachen kann
der bund zahlt abschläge bis zu 5000
euro bei solo selbstständigen und 10.000
euro pa unternehmen ein großteil der
abschlagszahlungen sei veranlasst alle
höheren beträge werden durch die länder
geprüft und ausgezahlt wir können
aktuell dort noch gar nicht in die
bearbeitung einsteigen
wir hoffen dass das anfang dezember der
fall ist und wir werden mit sicherheit
bis in den januar hinein auch prüfen und
auszahlungen durchführen müssen
der unternehmerin alice paulino dauert
das zu lange ihre finanziellen puffer
sind jetzt schon aufgebraucht
da fragen wir nach bayerischer kultur
banerjee in berlin
jacques unterlage jetzt gibt es also
streit über die großen summen für die
wirtschaft warum eigentlich war doch
bisher konsens dass sie im teil shutdown
unterstützt werden müssen so dass man
die wirtschaft weiter unterstützen will
das bleibt hier auch konsens allerdings
geht hier eine diskussion in berlin los
über die frage wie lange man das machen
kann und wie groß wie weit der umfang
sein sollte den diese häfen haben
sollten
kanzleramtschef brown hat heute schon
angemahnt sie seien aktuell nicht
zielgenau bundeswirtschaftsminister
altmaier der ja diese hilfen auch
mitgestaltet hat gesagt das wird man
nicht ewig so fortsetzen können und
beide kritisieren auch dass sich die
jetzigen hilfen am umsatz orientieren
und stimmen stimmen ihre disco
mitdiskutanten darauf ein dass man das
noch einmal überdenken wird den großen
streit den gibt es aktuell mit den
bundesländern die wehren sich heftig
gegen den vorwurf dass sie nicht genug
finanziell dazu beitragen zu diesen
hilfen und verweisen darauf dass sie
schon milliardenschwere hilfspakete und
auch bürgschaften übernommen haben
man sieht an dieser ganzen diskussion
dass sich bund und länder jetzt gedanken
darüber machen wie es weitergehen soll
auch im nächsten jahr man kann auch
davon ausgehen dass sich alle darauf
einstellen dass es weitere
einschränkungen gibt und damit auch
weitere hilfen für die wirtschaft geben
muss und was man auch ablesen kann an
der diskussion ist dass die hilfen im
kommenden jahr wahrscheinlich nicht mehr
so großzügig ausfallen werden wie in
diesem
die eine ordnung und der ausblick aufs
nächste jahr von chuck und erinnert wie
vielen dank dafür
hoffnung im kampf gegen diese pandemie
macht die impfstoffentwicklung in
rekordzeit
noch heute will der us-konzern mit
dörner als erstes unternehmen eine
zulassung in der eu beantragen
studien hätten eine wirksamkeit von mehr
als 94 prozent gezeigt eu kommission hat
sich bis zu 160 millionen dosen von dem
impfstoff gesichert auch in den usa will
madonna heute eine notfall zulassung
beantragen
wenn alles klappt wolle man noch im
dezember erste impfdosen verabreichen
vor moderner hatte bereits das deutsche
unternehmen bei montech zusammen mit dem
us-partner phase einer notfall zulassung
in den usa angemeldet wie oft haben wir
in diesem jahr das wort corona pandemie
benutzt sehr oft so oft dass auch die
gesellschaft für deutsche sprache nicht
anders konnte als corona pandemie zum
wort des jahres zu küren und damit ein
blick auf die jüngste zahlen zu
wochenbeginn sind die ja meistens
niedriger weil nicht alle
gesundheitsämter daten übermittelt haben
das robert koch institut meldet
innerhalb eines tages 11.000 169
neuinfektionen
das sind 305 fälle mehr als am montag
vor einer woche bundesweit die höchsten
zahlen verzeichnen immer noch zwei
regionen im bayerischen passau beträgt
die sieben tage incidents 570 und im
landkreis hildburghausen sind es 589
dort in thüringen beginnt morgen ein
freiwilliger massentest und wie sieht es
in ihrer region aus jederzeit nachlesen
können sie das online in unserer zdf
heute app dort gibt es für jede stadt
und jeden landkreis die aktuellen zahlen
ein umstrittenes thema in der korona
pandemie wie umgehen mit den schulen
dabei spielt der wechsel unterricht eine
zentrale rolle heißt ein teil der klasse
ist in der schule die anderen zu hause
im wechsel
das rki empfiehlt das ab 50
neuinfektionen pro 100000 einwohnern in
sieben tagen und und länder schlagen die
die möglichkeit erst ab einer inzidenz
von 200 vor schülerinnen und schüler in
frankfurt haben jetzt für mehr wechsel
unterricht demonstriert denken klingen
diese rund 300 schülerinnen und schüler
machten vor dem gesundheitsamt in
frankfurt klar sie wollen nicht mehr
frieren in vollen klassenräumen
sie sind für wechsel unterricht
schließlich liegt die inzidenz in
frankfurt bei über 200 wir glauben dass
in der aktuellen pandemischen lage der
wechsel unterricht heißt a und b wochen
eben ansammlungen schüler in der schule
in cern kann momentan ist es nicht
möglich abstand im klassenzimmer
einzuhalten wir sind 14 26 schüler das
kommt auf den kursen auf die klasse an
auch jetzt wegen weihnachten ich habe
jetzt angst meine oma anzustecken
das gesundheitsamt in frankfurt sieht
die schulen nicht als infektionsherde
und ist aktuell gegen ein wechselmodell
hier gehen sie mit anderen massnahmen
gegen die korona pandemie vor nehme ich
jemanden in quarantäne nehme ich mit
kontaktpersonen quarantäne wird getestet
wann wird getestet also wissen recht
komplexes thema wechsel unterricht das
ist nicht die alleinige lösung das kann
im ausnahmefall mal eine variante sein
aber nicht das ergebnis für den
virologen martin stürmer geht von den
schulen sehr wohl ein risiko aus der
alltags masken keinen hundertprozentigen
schutz bieten daher würde er vorbeugend
im privaten bereich haben wir im
augenblick eine sehr starke reduktion
der kontakte während in der schule im
klassenzimmer sitzen teilweise 25 30
jugendliche zusammen auf engstem raum
das sind 30 haushalte plus lehrer und
dementsprechend ist das ein bisschen
widersprüchlich für berufsschulen hat
die stadt frankfurt jetzt den wechsel
unterricht beschlossen
da die schülerinnen und schüler auch
sozialkontakte in ihren
ausbildungsbetrieben haben
für alle anderen ist dies allerdings
bislang nicht geplant
ausreichend schutzausrüstung ist in der
pandemie ganz entscheidend die
bundesregierung wird dazu eine
deutschlandweite gesundheits reserve
aufbauen
konkret geht es um masken beatmungsgerät
und medikamente sie sollen an 19
standorten im ganzen bundesgebiet
gelagert werden
der vorrat soll für
einen monat ausreichen überlastete
kliniken zu wenig intensivbetten das
will man in deutschland unbedingt
vermeiden
im nachbarland polen sind viele
krankenhäusern längst an ihre grenze
gestoßen über 500 todesfälle täglich gab
es in den vergangenen tagen im
zusammenhang mit cupid 19 und polen hat
nicht mal halb so viele einwohner wie
deutschland natalie steger berichtet
eine provisorische kühlhalle auf dem
friedhofsgelände im polnischen
czestochowa die letzten tage gab es in
polen meist mehr corona tote als in
deutschland auch wenn die zahl der
neuinfektionen sinkt war die tatsache
ist sehr beunruhigend dass die
sterblichkeit sehr hoch bleibt
sowohl bei den menschen mit begleitenden
krankheiten als auch bei menschen die
nur ankowitsch sterben laut experten ist
die hohe zahl an todesfällen die folge
der höchststände an neuinfektionen vor
zwei bis drei wochen die menschen
versterben jetzt die regierung gibt
heute ein ambitioniertes versprechen
jeder der positiv getestet und zu hause
ist soll so ein mobiles gerät erhalten
für die messung der sauerstoffsättigung
im blut
über eine app sollen die daten direkt an
ärzte gehen die bei sauerstoffmangel
reagieren so der plan
das programm ist ein sehr reales
instrument im kampf gegen die leider
große anzahl von todesfällen in den
letzten zwei wochen
wir haben hinweise dass patienten zu
spät in krankenhäuser eingeliefert
worden
doch polens gesundheitssystem ist auch
in nicht corona zeiten am anschlag
es fehlt ohnehin medizinisches personal
und den krankenhäusern jetzt material
pulsoximeter vielen städte druckmesser
wir haben zu wenige matratzen gegen
wundliegen geschwüre die sehr wichtig
für patienten sind die an
beatmungsgeräten liegen
derweil dürfen einkaufszentren seit
samstag wieder öffnen
auch an den kommenden adventssamstagen
soll geshoppt werden dürfen
allerdings sind die kundenzahlen pro
geschäft strengere
gilt die korona lage bleibt angespannt
in polen
die welt wird immer digitaler corona hat
dem zuletzt ja noch einen schub gegeben
auch in deutschland trotzdem hat es
hierzulande zum beispiel beim
breitbandausbau stichwort funklöcher
auch deswegen fördert die regierung seit
letztem jahr digitale projekte in
großstädten smart city heißt das ganze
da geht es etwa um die online
erreichbarkeit städtische verwaltungen
öffentliches internet oder parkplatz
reservierungen via app auch darmstadt
hatte sich beworben auf der liste des
smartesten deutschen städte immerhin auf
platz vier
stefan schlosser berichtet wenn die
altglas container geleert werden sind
diese ziemlich voll
im inneren sind sensoren verbaut die den
füllstand messen und in die zentrale
melden so kommt der lkw immer erst dann
wenn es wirklich nötig ist
wir versprechen uns je nach stand platz
eine einsparung von bis zu 20 prozent
und natürlich schon wird dadurch auch
die umwelt durch die verringerten
fahrten und durch die abrechnung nach
den fünf ständen durch die sensoren
sparen wir natürlich auch für die bürger
und für die stadt entsprechend die
kosten ein
digitale prozesse können umwelt und
lebensverhältnisse verbessern
mit hilfe dieser app lässt sich in
echtzeit genau verfolgen wo busse und
bahnen gerade fahren anschluss mit
carsharing oder mit bei kein problem mit
solchen lösungen will darmstadt zur
digital stadt werde bei einer digital
stadt geht es darum dass ihr mit den
technologischen mitteln die es gibt
sensoren apps alles was die
digitalisierung bietet es schaffen den
alltag der menschen zu erleichtern
prozesse zu vereinfachen abläufe zu
vereinfachen die uns alle zu gute kommen
das berufsschulzentrum nord mit seinen
über 5000 schülern ist technisch auf dem
neuesten stand
120 millionen euro wurden investiert
hybrid unterricht in der pandemie hier
kein problem
unser ziel ist es dass wir alle schulen
an das glasfasernetz anschließen das
haben wir im moment noch nicht aber wir
werden millionen investieren um das sehr
kurzfristig sicher zu stellen
auch freies wlan auf allen öffentlichen
plätzen und straßen soll es geben
aber von dieser digital vernetzten
zukunft wie in diesem werbevideo
dargestellt ist man auch in darmstadt
noch weit entfernt
in frankreich zeigen die proteste gegen
das geplante sicherheits gesetz wirkung
der umstrittenste paragraf der das
verbreiten von filmaufnahmen der polizei
im einsatz stark einschränken sollte
wird komplett überarbeitet das teilte
die regierung mit
hunderttausende warner wochenende
landesweit auf die straße gegangen weil
sie befürchten dass polizeigewalt
vertuscht werden könnte
teils kam es zu ausschreitungen auch
journalistinnen hatten sich massiv über
die gesetzesvorlage beklagt
indien hat global die zweitgrößte
bevölkerung entsprechend herausfordernd
ist der umgang mit krone
das land macht aber fortschritte
neuinfektionen und totenzahlen gehen
insgesamt zurück die hauptstadt neu
delhi meldet allerdings höchstwerte
immer mehr menschen in der millionen
stadt stecken sich an immer mehr sterben
wissenschaftler vermuten ein grund durch
den smog dort sind die lungen
angegriffen und 19 trifft also auf
menschen mit vorerkrankungen normen
odenthal über eine stadt in dem in der
man nur schwer atmen kann
das krematorium von dede baut aus neue
öfen neue feuer gruben corona fordert
opfer die hauptstadt ist ein hotspot im
rest des landes gehen die fallzahlen
runter in delhi steigen sie denn die hat
ein problem es versinkt im smog 20
millionen menschen müssen damit
zurechtkommen müssen damit leben
der smog ist in unseren augen sie tränen
das atmen fällt schwer und in diesem
nebel sieht man praktisch nichts mehr
für delhi ist das nicht neu immer wieder
solche bilder von sehenswürdigkeiten die
man nicht mehr sehen kann
die luft zum schneiden aber kaum noch
zum atmen in die praxis von dr gab
kommen immer mehr menschen mit den
typischen beschwerden der mediziner
stellt fest dass die schwere der
erkrankung zunimmt die behandlung
komplizierter wird die luftverschmutzung
greift natürlich unsere lungen an
und wenn die lunge schon vorgeschädigt
ist und dass corona virus setzt sich
oben drauf dann sind die folgen des
austritts das alltägliche leben
lebensgefährlich wie not but not sieht
nur eine chance geben
ich gehe überhaupt nicht mehr vor der
tür drinnen im haus haben wir einen
luftfilter installiert aber draußen hält
man es ja überhaupt nicht mehr aus in
diesen quellen
es sind die altbekannten probleme die
abgase des verkehrs der qualm der
industrie die brennenden felder der
bauern und dazu nun also corona eine
lösung nicht in sicht wie auch in diesem
dunst und uns für die arbeit und zum
sport und zur der sport meldung des
tages joachim löw darf weiter
rückendeckung für den bundestrainer von
der dfb-spitze heute bei einem treffen
in frankfurt die devise heißt offenbar
kein blick zurück im zorn stichwort das
0 6 gegen spanien sondern blick nach
vorn in richtung em nächstes jahr
frage an meinen kollegen markus harm in
frankfurt klingt ja so ein bisschen nach
augen zu und durch die pressemitteilung
vom dfb kam dann schon überraschend
schnell und es ist in der tat sehr nach
friede freude eierkuchen das motto vor
allem die aussagen in der presse
mitteilungen klingen sehr danach wir
gehen den gemeinsamen weg
uneingeschränkt weiter es gibt ein
klares konzept und die 0 6 niederlage
war nur ein einmaliger ausrutscher war
aber ist wohl auch joachim löw ist der
teuerste bundestrainer der welt der
bestbezahlte und eine trennung ist
deswegen natürlich auch sehr kostspielig
und in zeiten von corona und kurz vor
der em sich so eine riesige baustelle zu
schaffen und dann einen trainer zu
suchen das ist extrem kompliziert vor
allem echte nachfolger stehen irgendwie
nicht schlange und deswegen wird die em
entscheiden und der präsident fritz
keller hat schon gesagt minimalziel ist
das halbfinale
das bedeutet im umkehrschluss liefern
oder gehen für joachim löw danke markus
haben danke nach frankfurt
zur formel 1 nach seinem horror-unfall
gestern kann der franzose romain
grosjean das krankenhaus in bachrain
bereits morgen wieder verlassen
die behandlung der verbrennungen an
beiden handrücken erlitten hatte sei gut
verlaufen
dieser hügel über dem cockpit hat romain
grosjean das leben gerettet halo heißt
diese konstruktion zu deutsch
heiligenschein 2018 wurde halo gegen den
protest von fahrern und teamchefs
eingeführt weil er die sichtbehinderung
und zudem optisch nicht ansprechend sei
hieß es bei der einführung
ich war vor ein paar jahren auch nicht
dafür aber heute denke ich dass es die
größte verbesserung in der formel 1 ist
und ohne dieses teil könnte ich jetzt
nicht mit euch reden
halo war in der lage großchance kopf vor
der leitplanke zu schützen die durch die
form des autos horizontal gespalten
wurde und den boliden in zwei teile riss
aber auch das sogenannte hans system das
den kopf bei einem frontalaufprall
festhält hat ein übriges getan
und dank feuerfesten anzugs handschuhen
und schutzhaube unter dem helm hat
romain grosjean nur leichte verletzungen
erlitten
im vorletzten saisonrennen am kommenden
sonntag wird er links nicht starten
zum schluss schauen wir noch auf einen
koloss der heißt kann dann ist 18 meter
hoch und damit der größte seiner art
er durfte im japanischen yokohama seinen
ersten schritt machen
seit sechs jahren arbeiten die
entwicklung an dem roboter wiesen bis
früher neues 2022 soll er richtig laufen
lernen
nach dem kurzen ausflug heute hieß es
erst einmal gatter zu und gute nacht
morgen wird es im westen und süden über
winterlich mit glatteis und schnee
gefährliche aussichten gleich von katja
honnefer das war es von uns danke für
ihr interesse
zum heute journal erwartet sie claus
kleber um 21 uhr 45 und wir sind morgen
wieder zur stelle punkt 19 uhr einen
schönen abend wünschen wird
[Musik]
den abend meine damen und herren vieles
an heute die sonne einige allerdings
auch den nebel an der donau aber das
spannendste sind die wolken die von
nordwesten herankommen
denn die bringen regen jetzt heute
nachmittag lagen die temperaturen ja
noch um den gefrierpunkt aber heute
nacht sinken sie auf plus 4 bis minus 7
grad
es droht also eigentlich in ganz
deutschland bodenfrost und dann wird es
gefährlich wenn der regen hier von
nordwesten herankommt in den
mittelgebirgen wird rasch schnee daraus
bis morgen früh können also zehn
zentimeter neuschnee zusammenkommen
aber es gibt auch unterkühltes wasser
was auf dem gefrorenen boden fällt und
dann wird es spiegelglatt machen sie
sich also auch so gefährlichen
glatteisregen morgen früh zum
berufsverkehr in teilen von
baden-württemberg im saarland in
rheinland pfalz in hessen aber auch in
teilen von thüringen niedersachsen und
sachsen-anhalt gefasst richtung südosten
ist es eher schnee im nordwesten regen
im laufe des tages ziehen die
schneefälle weiter nach süden am
längsten schneit es noch zwischen dem
schwarzwald und im allgäu in
norddeutschland bleibt es morgen den
ganzen tag über trocken und trüb und die
temperaturen erreichen 0 bis 9 grad und
winterlich geht es dann auch in den
nächsten tagen weiter schönen abend noch